foreign
[Music]
my name is Dr pranabhalda I'm a
respiratory physician in Leicester in
the UK and I manage our TB service here
and today I'm going to talk to you about
um new evidence that uh suggests that
mycobactium tuberculosis which is the
cause of TB might actually be escaping
the lung and into the bloodstream
uh and in the presentation
um I will briefly give you an overview
of current TB epidemiology both uh
across the world and in the UK
um and then we'll talk a little bit
about
um what we understand of the
pathogenesis of human TB infection and
disease at the moment and of particular
interest for this talk will be our sort
of increasing awareness that although a
disease of the lungs
um mycobacterium tuberculosis does get
into the bloodstream
um and where and and this is both in
people who've got the disease but also
in people who just have the infection
um and this might have implications both
for what it means in terms of how the
infection evolves and uh and potentially
for new diagnostic tools
so you'll all be familiar that
tuberculosis is caused by a bacterium
called mycobacterium tuberculosis it's
part of a complex of genetically related
species
and we know from the the genotypic data
of mycobacterium tuberculosis that it
has coexisted with humans for over 60
000 years and actually accompanied
humans in their migration Out of Africa
what this means is that the organism is
very well adapted to the human host
and this makes it a very challenging
infection and disease to control and
clear
and that's reflected in the epidemiology
of TB worldwide because it remains one
of the top causes of death
um
globally
and we know that
um
the majority of TB is focused across
certain parts of the world so eight
countries account for approximately
two-thirds of global TB incidents now
and these countries are situated
primarily within the Indian subcontinent
in Central and sub-Saharan Africa and
China and Southeast Asia
and TB is actually an Exemplar for
disease caused by Health inequality so
whilst the Lord has been made of Health
inequality and the impacts has had
um during the covid-19 pandemic this is
something that has existed
um in tuberculosis for a long time
this is also reflected in the history of
tuberculosis in the UK so if we go back
a hundred years the epidemiology of TB
then looked quite different to what it
does now
and at the turn of the 20th century uh
shortly after shortly after the
Industrial Revolution was in full swing
tuberculosis rate in the UK were
comparable to those that we see in high
instance areas now across the world
um and this was driven really by people
migrating from rural areas into
overcrowded towns and cities which were
growing at the time
and these people were living in a very
overcrowded conditions with poor
sanitation and hygiene
and what we can see from the trends here
is that even before antibiotics became
available in the 1950s improvements in
General Health and well-being and
improvements in environment and
sanitation led to significant Falls uh
in TB rates
with antibiotic treatment being
introduced mortality rates from TB
plummeted and things continue to go in a
positive direction really until the mid
to late 1980s when the global HIV
epidemic took hold and migration rates
into
um
High income countries actually expanded
so we know from migration trends that
the countries affected most by TB
um in uh at the moment are countries
from which a lot of migration occurs
into
low incidents High income countries of
today and actually the vast majority of
TB in these countries is driven by by
migrants by by migration
however people don't come into a country
with TB
um they usually come in they usually
migrate having got latent TB infection
and this later reactivates uh into
tuberculosis in the UK approximately 70
to 75 percent of cases we see are in
migrants
as I said I work in Leicester which is
shown here by a red circle this is in
the center of England and is one of a
few TB hot spots around the country and
this again reflects the migration
patterns into into the UK so most of the
TB we see in this country occurs in
inner city multi-ethnic
areas with high population density
Leicester is a is a very ethnically
diverse city
um
uh and and sees uh and as a result of
that really sees a lot of TB coming from
the Indian subcontinent
so moving on now and thinking a bit
about uh the pathobiology of
microbacterium tuberculosis infection as
you will know
um the infection is transmitted in
aerosol and uh susceptible recipient of
infected aerosol
um will acquire the infection
into their lungs so the organism passes
into the the lower Airways
um and
um because the size of aerosols it'll
get down into distal respiratory tract
uh into what we call the alveolar sacs
and there the uh the pathogen will
encounter various different immune cells
so alveolar macrophages will recognize
it as a as an invading organism and the
First Response the innate immune
response will be to internalize and
ingest the organism in an attempt to
clear the infection
um and
um when it does so because the organism
is so well adapted to the human immune
system a lot of the time the infection
cannot be cleared in this way and an
infected macrophage rather than clearing
the infection simply acquires the
infection
an infected macrophage will then
stimulate other macrophages to the site
of the infection and together slowly
they will develop what we call an innate
granuloma which is a cluster of
macrophages
surrounding a group of infected
macrophages
now alongside this there are patrolling
immune cells which include monocytes and
dendritic cells and their role really is
to internalize the organism and present
it to T cells within lymph nodes
um and there the T cells get activated
and they come to the site of infection
and a proper granulomar is then formed
so the idea really is that the immune
cells if they're unable to eradicate the
infection will contain it within these
granules that you can see and in the
vast majority of cases this strategy is
very effective however in a small
minority
either because of problems with the
immune response or because of the
virulence of the pathogen it overcomes
the granuloma when the granuloma was
disrupted and this then leads to
cavitation cavity formation within the
lung and allows the bacteria to escape
out of the lung and potentially be
transmitted to other people
so most of the pathobiology that that we
know is is essentially what is happening
in the lungs and that's reflected here
in a patient with TB where you can see
large cavities on the chest x-ray big
holes
where this damage has occurred
however we recognize
that a significant proportion of people
have what we call extra pulmonary TB so
this is disease that affects organs
outside of the lung
and in the UK approximately half of all
cases we see are extra pulmonary so the
question really is how did the TB get
outside the lung and into these
different organs the pictures you can
see here show an infection in the Pro
patient and in another in the bones near
the ankles
so there is plenty of evidence to
support the idea that uh mycobacterium
tuberculosis can escape from the lung to
other sites through the bloodstream so
the there's a circumstantial evidence
that I've just been telling you about
where we know from uh sites where TB
occurs that it must have escaped from
the lawn and it could only have done so
through the bloodstream we know that in
people who are severely unwell with TB
um particularly children and those with
severe immunodeficiency from HIV will
often have
disseminated disease where tuberculosis
is where their whole body is riddled
with tuberculosis and you can and you
can often detect the organism and
culture in in the bloodstream
and a historically studies in
um in necropsy studies
who have basically been done which have
identified
tuberculous lesions in organs outside
the lung in people who died from TB but
also in people who died from other
causes
and did and never had TB during their
during their lifetimes and in those
people of particular interest when they
took some of the extract from the
apparent tuberculous lesions and then
inoculated susceptible animals usually
guinea pigs they were able to they then
also developed a tuberculous lesion
which would suggest that although these
people never had TB they did have viable
bacilli that was sitting in organs
outside the lung
one of the first reports of being able
to culture mycobacterium tuberculosis
from blood comes from 1914
and here a Dr Faber basically makes some
very poignant observations he notes that
it was notoriously difficult and that
there were very few organisms which were
buried in the mass of red cells in
fibrin and this obviously these are
Inhibitors to achieving a successful
culture and he concludes that it was a
matter of good fortune that he was able
to able to show a positive result so
this is not so although I guess one of
the things to sort of take from this is
that although we don't routinely detect
mycobacterium tuberculosis in blood that
may not necessarily reflect the fact
that it's not there but more that it's
difficult to show
foreign
in terms of how the how the organism
gets out of the lung well there are two
potential Pathways so we know for
example that uh to uh the organism is
actually transported out of the lung
through the lymphatics and uh that's
shown on the left hand side where you
can see that the lymphatic drainage in
the lungs is usually from the outsides
of the lungs towards the center and
eventually the lymphatic ducts will
converge on the right to the right
lymphatic duct and to the left uh to the
thoracic duct and these these lymphatic
ducts will then drain directly into the
bloodstream
the other way in which the organisms can
get into the bloodstream is actually by
directly moving from the alveoli into
the network of capillaries that exist
um as a bed surrounding the alveoli
they're actually in very close proximity
to the alveoli so it wouldn't be a it
wouldn't be a huge step to translocate
from within the alveolus to outside
and there's uh
further evidence to support this so this
is a on the left hand side you can see a
recent study which looked at
um the differences in tissue between
a tissue that didn't have the in which
macrophages were
healthy and in tissue from mice where
macrophages were infected with
mycobacterium tuberculosis and what
these slides show is that the is that
infection with micro bacterium
tuberculosis essentially induces what we
call angiogenesis so it induces the
proliferation of blood vessels so this
sort of suggests that the infection
itself is encouraging blood vessel
formation which will which presumably is
to support its transport out of the lung
on the right hand side you can see
a CT scan of a human lung where they
have drawn on where the blood vessels
are and there's a computer model at the
bottom here which shows that around the
granulomas which are in yellow there's
extensive network of blood vessels C so
this again is in keeping with the idea
that infection induces blood vessel
proliferation
and going back to the point about you
know how how the organism actually gets
away from the lung there are effectively
two ways this could happen it either
walks or it gets a lift so that's shown
here on the left hand side so the idea
really is that the organism could
directly infect the epithelial cells
around the alveoli and walk across
essentially into the blood vessels at
the bottom
or more likely uh and probably more
commonly the infection basically takes a
ride in one of the immune cells
um which which
essentially ingests it and either
transports it or tries to or tries to
kill it but in failing to do so it
effectively acts as a vehicle to carry
it outside the lung and that's shown
here on the right hand side and is known
as the Trojan Horse Theory
so I'm now going to talk to you a little
bit about some clinical studies uh that
have looked at mycobacterium
tuberculosis involvement infection this
is a study done in Vietnam in children
um where they took consecutive people
with suspected TB
um that came into hospital and then
essentially tried to perform
mycobacterium tuberculosis culture
alongside routine tests for TB and they
categorize the patient into those who
had culture confirmed TB from uh from
from sputum those in whom there wasn't
culture confirmation but they still did
blood cultures and those in whom the
diagnosis of TB was unlikely and what
you can see here is that
in children where a confirmed diagnosis
of TB was made approximately 10 to 11
percent you could find evidence of TB in
the blood uh with culture
um if you look at the list of patients
that were identified with uh with
culture positive TB in blood what you
find is there's a bit of a theme in that
all of them had virtually all of them
had as effectively very severe disease
so they either had meningitis or they
had clear evidence of dissemination
so this sort of this this study kind of
brings out some Salient points namely
that it's difficult to culture
mycobacterium tuberculosis unless you've
got very severe disease and you're very
unwell
uh and that sort of corroborated in
these other studies so this study on the
left hand side looked at the phenotypes
of disease that correlate with a
positive blood culture uh and you can
see here that
um this wasn't in blood culture that was
actually using molecular methods but you
can see here that the closest
correspondence was seen in panel B which
was disseminated TB in other forms of TB
the um the the association between a
positive identification of TB in the
blood and having the disease was much
poorer
um and then on the right hand uh slide
you can right hand side the slide you
can see that in patients that have
um evidence of MTB in the blood their
prognosis in terms of survival is
significantly poorer so this was in an
HIV positive cohort and those who had
evidence of MTB in their blood had a
higher mortality than those who didn't
or who had attended hospital for other
reasons
so there has been a Metro analysis uh
published a few years ago now that
examined
um the uh the incidence or the
prevalence of mycobacterium tuberculosis
in Blood and and what it found was that
uh in in terms of
um culture positivity
the overall rate of detection of
mycobacterium tubular system blood was
around 15
in hiv-positive adults
in children
um the proportions were significantly
lower so again this is
um in keeping with the idea that
children tend to have a lower sort of
Distillery load associated with disease
now we've been doing a meta-analysis
looking at HIV negative people so people
who are immunocompetent and this is a a
a a metropolysis that is currently under
review but what it shows is that the
yield you're using culture in these
cohorts is virtually zero
but that if you use molecular methods
then studies suggest that you may find a
detection rate of up to 15
in HIV negative immunocompetent
cohorts with TB
um now why is it important to
potentially important to i to be able to
identify MTB in blood well it's another
it's another portal for making diagnosis
and this paper I sort of summarize the
potential value of being able to do so
so this was in a in a South African
cohort that was predominantly HIV
positive and around a third of patients
in this coal had a positive blood
culture and what the authors uh report
here and describe is that in in a
population with a high incidence of
multi-drug resistant TB
there was value in being able to detect
the organism in blood for informing
um the phenotype of drug
sensitivity in people in whom sputum
failed
so thinking about this more broadly
we know in our own practice here in the
UK that approximately 30 to 40 percent
of people who present to us with
pulmonary TB are unable to produce
sputum so having tests that allow us to
take samples for Diagnostic purposes
that don't rely on the patient having to
produce sputum could potentially improve
our ability to diagnose the condition
and in this case as an example by by
sort of focusing on the pathogen you're
also getting information about their
drug susceptibility
so just a few more slides here about
molecular methods so um this paper this
paper sort of this result here on the
left hand side basically shows that
um the molecular methods that we
commonly use
um in sputum
um are not optimized really for use in
blood so uh here uh this this study
looked at whether the expert MTB riff
could be to detect MTB in Blood and this
was the uh the first version of the of
the assay and they compared
um
uh and what they found was that
essentially eight eight percent of
people with culture confirmed TB uh
could could would be detected in Blood
using the acid
um however first since then what we what
we've understood is that one of the
barriers to using these assays is the
fact that red blood cells
um fibrin uh these all uh affect the um
the performance of the PCR and actually
if you're able to use larger blood
volumes then you can improve the
sensitive to the molecular method so
this study here
um shows that when you increase the
blood volume which is study B compared
to study a you can improve the
sensitivity
of molecular methods
um by a considerable margin
um
and another study here shows actually
the other thing that's important the
sort of anticoagulant that you use to
collect the blood so because in the in
the vast majority of cases the
mycobacterium blood is not actually
three mycopactorium but within white
blood cells most of these assays focus
on collecting the white blood cell
fraction of whole blood and so when
collecting whole blood this study shows
that
um an as citrate dextrose-based
anticoagulant actually performs better
for collecting the blood than EDTA does
and the yield from PCR is is increased
in that way so there are clearly steps
that can be taken towards optimizing
these assets to improve their
performance
now we've been using an assay called the
active phage assay which is a two-phase
blood-based
bacteriophage-based assay to identify uh
MTB in Blood and the way that it works
is is shown here so we collect whole
blood and then separate out the
peripheral blood model nuclear cells and
then this fraction is taken and
incubated with a bacteriophage the d29
bacteriophage which essentially infects
and lies
mycobacterium tuberculosis or several
mycobacterial species actually
which are metabolically active
and once the license has taken place
the DNA can be collected and cleaned and
then run on a PCR to be able to then
detect
um and detect the microbacterial
infection and this process essentially
enhances the sensitivity
of an ability to to be able to detect
MTB DNA in Blood and because it's a
phage based assay you know that the DNA
that you're measuring is coming from
bacteria which were metabolically active
and viable
and this stuff this act this assay which
was first developed to detect animal
mycobacterial infections uh we basically
collaborated
um with the inventors to examine whether
it works uh whether it could work in in
human infection
so we did a study a few years ago now
um looking at patients with pulmonary TB
coming to our clinic so these were
pulmonary TB suspects and we basically
stratified them into those where a
diagnosis of TB was made and those in
whom an alternative diagnosis was made
um and we performed the active age test
before they started any treatment
in those who had pulmonary TB we also
recruited their contacts and performed
screening for TB infection and basically
stratified them into those who had
latent TB infection and those who had no
TB infection based on a based on a
quantifier on the interferon gamma
release asset
and then they were also followed up for
12 months
so what we found comparing people with
TB uh with those who presented with
symptoms were found not to have TB was
that actually the assay was very
sensitive and specific so in 11 out of
15 people with palmary TB the actophage
assay was positive and the key
differences between
patients in whom we got a positive
result compared to patients in whom got
a negative result was really in the
extent of disease that we could see
clinically so people with a positive
active age result tended to have more
disease on their chest x-ray they had
high degrees of inflammation measuring
the CRP and there they had a shorter
time to positive culture from sputum so
all of these would indicate a higher
basiliary load and therefore possibly
reflecting the fact that there's a limit
of detection with the actophage assay
that we were achieving in this group
compared with the non-tb group where
none of the patients that we recruited
had a positive assay so the specificity
of the assay in this cohort was was a
hundred percent
now what was also interesting was when
we looked at the the TB contacts
um so those who were positive on the
quantiferon test we had 18 uh such
people and three of them were positive
with the active age test at Baseline
these people followed up for 12 months
and two of the three people who were
active age positive went on to develop
TB after a period of seven months so
they didn't have active TB at the time
they were recruited and they were
followed at three monthly intervals for
12 months so this TB essentially
developed During the period of
observation which suggests that
that firstly that you can see uh
circulating mycobacteria in people who
don't have disease but also that that
might tell us about the risk that person
has of developing TB in the future
now since that publication there's been
another larger publication uh last year
where using a digital PCR
authors reported significant rates of
MTB DNA detection in
um in healthy cohorts who were both
agronegative and igra-positive
um so these are people who had
immunological evidence of TB infection
or not and in both groups there was
evidence that you could identify MTB DNA
in their blood that DNA was
predominantly seen in cd34 stem cells
which sort of flux in and out of the
bone marrow
um and what was interesting was that the
proportion of people
um with a positive
MTB or the prevalence of MTB DNA in
blood was higher in people who are
quantifier and positive compared to
those who are quantity or negative in
those who were HIV uninfected however
the HIV infected
um cohort
uh the that that proportion was reversed
suggesting that actually
um those eager negatives were false
negatives as a consequence of HIV
so that that data rule seems to fit
together
um and the other interesting finding in
this study was that after they received
treatment for TB infection the rates of
positivity in blood are significantly
dropped
which would suggest that the DNA that
we're seeing here is not just remnants
of previous infection but actually a
consequence of existing uh infection
now more recently
um we've done a study which is sort of
under review at the moment where we were
progressing the idea that identifying
MTB DNA in the blood of people with
latent infection might associate with
increased TB risk and the way we wanted
to evaluate this was using a highly
sensitive Imaging method called PET CT
which gives you both structural
information but also metabolic
information about activity inside the
body and we've recruited a cohort of
recent TB contacts and performed PET CT
scans in them to get information about
the status of their infection inside the
lungs now these the images we get with
PET CT are much more sensitive than what
you can see on a chest x-ray or even a
normal CT scan so it gives you much more
information about what's going on and on
that basis we were able to identify
three patterns of infection in the lung
so in one group the small group there
was no evidence of activity which
suggest that even though these contacts
have been exposed to TB there was an
Evidence of infection so they hadn't
acquired the infection but there were
two other groups a positive group where
there was a considerable uptake in
activity usually in and around the lung
and an indeterminate group where there
was a lower degree of uptake but also
but it at sites where you might expect
to see TB infection
all of these people had an active age
test done at Baseline and they were all
followed up
and those who had a positive PET CT scan
we also
um
performed
um sampling from the sites where we
could where we saw uptake
so what we had here is in the positive
PET CT group uh four out of 10 people
actually we were able to culture MTB
from their lymph nodes around the lung
and in one case from the lung itself
from a lavage
um and in seven out of ten the active
age test was positive in the
indeterminate group we weren't able to
get any samples or positive cultures but
four out of six people in that group
were active age positive and in the
negative group we had one positive
active age test
um we then looked also at performing so
those who had a positive mycobactium
culture from the lung we treated the TB
infection
in the remainder We performed a second
PET CT scan after three months uh and
didn't give them treatment and simply
followed them up on that basis
and in those people where there was
evidence of progressive change over that
three-month period we then concluded
that they had a progressive form of MTB
infection and we then decided to treat
them
now when we compared the active phase
positive group to those reactive phase
negative we found a significant
association between having a positive
active age test and having either a
positive culture
um following a PET CT scan or evidence
of progressive infection when you
perform serial PET CT scan which
suggests that actually being able to
detect MTB in the blood correlates with
an increased risk of developing disease
so essentially correlates with a higher
potentially a higher basiliary burden
and a higher risk of progressive
infection
so really to summarize and conclude then
um what we can say is that human MTB
infection is very complex it starts in
the lung but is likely to be more
widespread than we currently appreciate
there is emerging evidence that MTB can
escape into the bloodstream more often
than we think and actually in a wider
spectrum of infection than we previously
appreciated so that includes both
immunocompetent and immune compromised
cohorts with TB but also cohorts that
just have the infection and not the
disease
and uh our data also suggests that the
mechanisms leading to dissemination may
be different according to whether it
occurs as part of infection or whether
it occurs as part of disease and this is
a piece of work that's ongoing at the
moment but it's really quite clear that
um
our
perspective that TB is simply a disease
of the lungs may not be necessarily
entirely accurate thanks